Build it. Draw it. Play it.
Vsauce! This is your home for some of the
coolest creations from everyday people. This
is BiDiPi.
Build It
Three separate Czech companies have come together
to create the world's first fully capable
flying bicycle. Using what looks like a mountain
bike frame, and two large turbine fans, they're
able to create enough lift for 5 minutes of
flight with a test dummy on board. The idea
stems from a famous Czech comic strip character
named Jan Tlesklac, who was always trying
to create a flying bicycle.
Inspired by Dutch engineer and sculptor Theo
Jansen, Jason Allenman built this unique variation
of a Strandbeest sculpture out of Lego. A
Strandbeest, which means Beach Beast in Dutch,
is a large animal-like sculpture made out
of lightweight materials. They're propelled
by wind and have a distinctive style of motion
defined by their many spindly legs. Jason's
motorized LEGO version is a walking steam
punk inspired fortress, complete with working
windows and doors.
Handcrafted from high density plywood, mahogany
veneer, solid brass trim, and glass, Colin
Johnson's the Emperor's Cabinet is a wet bar
built to look like an AT-AT walker from Star
Wars. It's currently on display in Vancouver
at the Hot Art, Wet City gallery for their
May LaForge be with You exhibition, which
focuses on art based on Star Wars and Star
Trek.
Anthony Howe is a sculptor who builds intricate,
wind powered metal sculptures. About Face
is his examination of the human face, and
is built from copper and stainless steel.
At almost 7 1/2 feet tall, About Face is made
up of 100 individually balanced and weighted
copper panels - some free swinging and others
articulated by spinning stainless cups. As
wind interacts with the sculpture, it creates
a hypnotic, surreal effect of changing expressions
and distorted symmetry.
Draw It
AMMO is a photo series by artist Sabine Pearlman
that reveals the inner workings of various
pieces of ammunition. The series was shot
on a WWII era bunker in Switzerland. He believes
that the intricate beautiful nature of the
form inside the ammunition is so vastly different
than the destructive purpose of the object.
Artist Kode Logic created "Iron Mash" a series
of prints that mix Iron man with a variety
of other fictional characters including Darth
Vader, Superman, Wolverine, and Predator.
And now for the book paintings of Ekaterina
Panikanova
Evolution is a project from Tyler Rhodes that
was made to teach people about evolution and
art. The animation series is a collaboration
of 5 groups of people and 460 drawings. This
one is from the Patrick Henry School of Science
and Art and is made out of around 100 of their
handmade creatures.
Play It
The Badpiper is the worlds only flame throwing
bagpipe artist. Here is performing ACDC's
Thunderstruck in Australia.
Unlocking the Truth is a sixth grade heavy
metal band. Here they are playing one of their
songs in Times Square
Finally sludge metal giants Kylesa have just
released the video for their song "Unspoken"
directed by Brodie Rush with art by Tyson
Schroeder
Submit your BiDiPis as a personal message
here on YouTube. Or share them with everyone
over at Facebook.com/VsauceTwo.
Click here to listen to a brand new installment
of BiDiPi Radio. Music created and submitted
by you guys. Also, check out YOUR BiDiPi.
An entire video dedicated to your creations.
And as always - thanks
for watching.